[Aplausos]
o
meu jeito
[Música]
o lote olha só a beleza e potência
cabelo agora não parece mais um pokémon
que lançou pokémon gol no brasil é e
[Aplausos]
todo mundo para jogar pokémon go a
pessoa que assistia pokémon as pessoas
que não assistiu até que assistir
digimon pode jogar pokémon muita gente
que nem meu deus é o pokémon gol cada
pokémon do brasil e do mundo no brasil
assistirá digimon na escola escola era
dividida entre os pokémon de junho o
desmonte a pokémon hoje eu vi foi bem
foi márcio foi a pessoa que capturar um
pokémon quanto posso conquistar tudo o
salão para casa eu baixei também esse
jogo joguei só que eu baixei eu apaguei
que não há dinheiro para passar um dia
na pena 40 pokémon no final do dia não
tem mais um salário e têm muitas
autópsia na rua mexer no celular já é
perigoso mas não sei lá pra cima olhando
em pokémon lugar e edu está fazendo o
que estou procurando um pokémon que está
ligado e itaporã com quem melhor com que
a célula assaltante rouba tanto seu lado
que está procurando um pokémon porque os
assaltante assistiu digimon a para o
cachorro é [__] porque fui até música
porque fica fica fica a briga
[Música]
caso a fifa todo mundo pra cachorro era
porque de todos o pikachu também evoluem
e todo mundo gosta mais do que cachorro
a explicação tudo que tem feito o povo
gosta não adianta o povo gosta picanha
benfica porto gosta picapau temp por
gosto e acho que o povo gosta
homem gosta de todo mundo fala que vai
baixar o jogo vai jogar até o menino de
oito anos jogando pokémon domingo
assistindo pokémon
daí nossa gente a assistir bakugan
aguentar com pokémon gold sala ainda
conseguir capturar 15 pokémon três
prêmios dois irmãos de 10 mil em aos
pokémon tem evoluído de gênio volta à
cidade está tudo igual padrão por
exemplo para vocês e pokémon gold me
trouxe a revelação é constrangedora para
mim que não tinha noção do quanto minha
casa ainda que quando eu voltava a
câmera por lá tinham relatado esse lado
a pessoa que eu tô matar em cima do
negócio natais basta empatar em cima da
cama e matando um saco de batata para
baixo o jogo pensando que vai jogar
naquela emoção do pokémon equipe rocket
mamãe sabe quando quer realizar qualquer
lugar está tomando conta do brasil mesmo
tempo que fala um alerta aqui pra dar
pra vocês e invadindo até a medicina eu
vou menino de deus lá na minha cidade
nasceu tão feio mas tão feio
foi o minas em minas eu tão fake quando
me pegou pelas pernas que subiu na
flotilha na câmera aqui o mototáxi não
falo do meu filho e meu cachorro bassalo
doutor é isso aí o rapaz se você gostou
do vídeo é claro clique em gostei
aqui no youtube é o segundo canal mais
influente do youtube do mundo inteiro
graças a vocês é um top
vocês são todas são muito top posição
própria óxido nítrico em voltei aqui no
youtube não se esquece voltar lá no
facebook de um pouco esse vídeo e curte
o vídeo lá no facebook lá na porta de um
vídeo novo você quer para os seus amigos
comentaram que joga pokémon gold gorp
pokémon e comenta aqui embaixo no
youtube agora se você fosse um pokémon
qual pokémon você seria como é que no
youtube
fala galera obrigado a assistir tv e até
aqui é na e meus prêmios nick também eu
estou concorrendo na categoria humorista
vai lá melhor humorista volta já tenha
forte lá é só clicar revolta quantas
vezes quiser por dia se quiser votar
melhor o youtube e você pode falar no
joelho conselho que está concorrendo no
concelho baixa do concelho meu brother é
isso aí
valeu galera vamos juntos aos pokémon